In addition to the rash, I seem to be rotating fluid, arms legs face, puffy. Could this be related to kidney function or allergic reaction or other.
So when you're retaining fluids and you're getting puffyness, you think of things like, okay, is there blocked, lymphatic.
Certainly, if you're getting fluid in your face, your face is getting puffy and your arms and legs, then you don't think so much lymphatic.
So you think lymphatic, as if if both your legs are swelling or your one arm is swelling after surgery or something like that, there's a blocked lymphatic drainage.
When you have more systemic fluid, you think of things like allergy to something and when you have systemic inflammation like that, you think that I can reaction to a medication.
That's what I would think of.
Certainly, kidney function. So you're on the right track with that. Your kidneys are what drain that. And certainly kidney function could affect that too.
I would definitely get some blood work to make sure your kidney function is within normal limits and that's cleared up.
Okay, sorry, it's finished. That's for my blood work yesterday, my hisinophils are high. So what we're raising is sinophils.
Is different parasitic infections, fungal infections, most commonly there is his hisinophils is allergic reaction.
So parasitic infections, fungal infections, you don't think that that ties to increase in retained retention and fluid. So that doesn't fit the piece there.
In allergic reaction, certainly ties into retained fluid and elevated the hisinophils.
So I'd be concerned about possible reaction to a medication.
So a person can have so let's say a person's not on any medication whatsoever. And they go in for a blood test and let's say they have really bad allergy issues. Let's say like, um, you know, allergies to pollen or something like that seasonal allergies.
If you get a standard CBC gun, you know, at a physical, they could have elevated just slightly elevated hisinophils that has to do with that that allergy that they're their seasonal allergies.
If a person doesn't isn't probe the seasonal allergies has never known to have elevated hisinophils at different times in the year.
So one different medications and they have elevated hisinophils, plus the retention of fluid. I would definitely talk to the prescribing doctor about possible reaction to a medication.
As far as what relief you could do to that, always you want to find the reason why. So you want to do what I just said and check it to talk to your prescribing doctor about that.
As far as you got to figure out the reason why first before you start trying to solve the problem.